[Music]
one sweltering evening on the streets of
minneapolis
yet another black man falls victim to
police brutality
they murdered my brother
the killing of george floyd has sparked
outrage not only across america
but also across the entire world
it just can't be an american movement
but it has to be a worldwide movement
it is the latest chapter in the history
of racial injustice
that is as old as the country itself we
are fighting an institutional systemic
problem that has been allowed to
permeate
since we were brought to this show
[Music]
with the nation as divided as it has
ever been
what will it take for america and the
rest of the world to guarantee
that black lives really do matter
[Music]
george floyd was born in fayetteville
north carolina in 1973.
he grew up in texas and moved to
minnesota where he worked as a truck
driver and a security guard
a father of five mr floyd's life was not
much different for millions of his
fellow americans
but the nature of his death could change
the course of history
it's monday evening in minneapolis
four police officers have responded to a
call a legend a man has used a
counterfeit twenty dollar bill to buy a
packet of cigarettes
george floyd is arrested handcuffed and
now pinned to the ground by one of the
officers
you could have [ __ ] put him in the
car by now bro he's not resisting the
rest or nothing
the officer pictured is derek chauvin
he ignores the protest from onlookers
and continues to apply pressure on mr
floyd's neck
officer is an 18-year veteran of the
police department
in that time over a dozen complaints
have been lodged against him
my stomach my neck
george floyd clearly states 16 times
i can't breathe
is oblivious to his cries
get back on the street are you serious
bro are you serious and you're going to
keep here you're going to keep
do you want to keep your thing on your
neck even when the paramedics arrive to
assist a man clearly in distress
chauvin continues the chokehold
chauvin has applied pressure to his neck
for 8 minutes and 46 seconds
and later that evening george is
pronounced dead
honestly i haven't watched the full
video because
you know for the past few years we've
been flooded with
imagery and um footage of black people
being killed
by the hands of law enforcement or white
vigilantes
and my heart my soul my spirit just
couldn't take anymore
[Applause]
within 24 hours the death of another
black man in police custody unleashes a
fury
that has existed for generations
everybody's expressing anger everybody's
expressing all
it's been going on for way too many
years and it is time for a change
because
we are tired
[Applause]
the killing of george floyd brings both
black and white demonstrators onto the
[Applause]
[Music]
streets
[Applause]
and mr floyd's family is clear exactly
what justice they are seeking
i would like for those officers to be
charged
with murder because that's exactly
what they did they murdered my breath
it is later announced that the four
officers have been fired
and the fbi is investigating the killing
in a drive for equality they planned
non-violent action
but violence erupted often in one of the
founding principles of the united states
is that all men are created equal
but for generations many black americans
have pointed out the inescapable fact
that the nation was founded on
inequality and the exploitation of their
ancestors
america and britain were built on the
backs of slaves
occupied and colonized people and so
they would have been that in common our
center color reflects
rapid pillage
women had no choice but to have babies
of white men
who were not who were not on their
children the first president owned
on slaves uh
when lincoln was killed uh they removed
the troops
jim crow laws came in closer rigid
apartheid said
in america i think education is
extremely important
and i think when we understand
historical facts
right that it makes all the difference
in the world
and you know what is the harm and
understanding
that africa for example is the
birthplace of civilization
that that the people weren't savages
but on the contrary they were architects
farmers
priests scholars etc
[Music]
the civil rights movement of the 1960s
is an era of hope
when figures such as dr martin luther
king confront american racism
head-on
[Applause]
[Music]
while other figures such as malcolm x
helped to inspire an entire generation
who are you you don't know don't tell me
negro that's nothing for you before the
white man needs you a negro
young people were demonstrating marching
protesting for a quality life right
they were marching protesting for
integration
for quality education for
health care for housing and my father
came along
and said we demand our human rights as
your brother
we demand our human rights ordained by
god
despite bitter opposition particularly
in the south
the government in washington accepts the
country has to change now they march
under a federal court order
and with the protection of federalized
national guard units and regular troops
in the sixth remarks for public
condition law the right to vote
the day dr king gave the speech in
texas florida maryland we can use a
second public toilet
we can buy ice cream and hobbies or we
could run the hotel room
the low long chain behavior change
largely we go go to school together
begin to become more civil
so we're overcoming the the the impact
of race supremacy
uh it's a very slow and painful journey
but we're
that's our fight the tide seems
unstoppable
and the civil rights movement begins to
secure greater political
social and economic justice
[Music]
but the racists fight back and dr king
is shot dead in memphis tennessee
my reaction to the reverend king let me
put it like this
he was he was assassinated at tea time
on april 4th 1968.
i was standing in the mirror in the
bathroom at home styling my hair when
the news came over the radio
from that day till about last year i
literally could not hear
his voice that's how traumatic
it was for me it's still traumatic for
me he was the father of our generation
he was our father but when he was
assassinated i think
for a lot of us i wouldn't say we gave
up we didn't give up
on witnessing the murder of a man who
has preached peaceful means to achieve
equality
black america vents his rage against
those who refuse to accept justice
[Music]
23 years after dr king's murder racist
violence by the police is back in the
headlines around the world
in 1991 a home video captures the savage
beating of rodney king
by four police officers in los angeles
i'm glad i'm not dead that's all when
this happened
like i say it didn't surprise me and i
think probably
it didn't surprise a lot of people is
that we saw it
because i think almost every
african-american person has a story like
that somewhere down
you know the tree somewhere it's there
when you see it
that's when it goes inside of you that's
when it gets you
you know the lapd the los angeles police
department
are particularly notorious um
and anybody who's hispanic or
african-american they know about the
lapd
so this wasn't a surprise in and of
itself but if somebody had presence of
mind to capture it
is the surprise the following year
the officers are acquitted of excessive
use of force
soon after the verdict fueled by a
mixture of fury and disbelief
protesters take to the streets
within hours los angeles is in flames
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states
so help you god so help me god
congratulations mr president
sixteen years later with the election of
the first black president
there is widespread hope that america
can at last begin to heal
but despite the historic achievement
there is still anger and justice on the
streets
[Applause]
in 2012 in florida 17 year old black
american trayvon martin is shot dead by
a member of the neighborhood watch
when his killer george zimmerman is
acquitted there are widespread protests
trayvon's death leads to the formation
of an international human rights
organization
black lives matter black lives matter
um started in 2013
in the death of trayvon martin by the
hands of a
white vigilante named george zimmerman
and it just started off with just you
know a simple post
on facebook and it grew into a hashtag
and grew into it like a rallying call
founded by oprah tometti alicia garza
and patrice coolers
blm demands an affirmation of black
folks humanity
and a recognition of our contribution to
this society
and our resilience in the face of deadly
oppression
support for the movement increases
following an incident in new york
in july 2014.
police officers confront 43 year old
father of six
eric garner
and place him in a chokehold
put your hand behind him
he is heard saying i can't breathe 11
times
the medical examiner records his death
as a homicide
the officers surrounding mr ghana as he
chokes to death
escape any charges
we realize that our lives do not matter
to so many other people
and is not recognized by the system
that's working to dehumanize us
and oppressing us we're not saying that
our lives matter to anybody else's
we're saying that black lives matter
just as much as anybody else's
and we deserve quality life just like
anyone else
[Applause]
[Music]
by spring of this year america is fully
in the grip of the coronavirus
we're now in the critical care area of
the emergency department
everyone that's in here today is here
due to breathing problems
almost uniformly all from coven
[Music]
we all know that we have to reach a
certain point and that point is going to
be
a horrific point in terms of death
and the next week and a half two weeks
are going to be
i think they're going to be very
difficult
[Music]
politicians are quick to insist that the
virus affects everyone equally
but the harsh reality is that african
americans are three times more likely to
die from kovid 19 than white americans
the killing of george floyd occurs when
42 million americans are unemployed
and once again police brutality and
economic injustice
combined to cause an explosion of
outrage
within 48 hours of the killing of george
floyd
demonstrations are spreading across the
united states
[Applause]
some are spontaneous but many are
organized by black lives matter
i think it's amazing that we're in this
moment where
black people are forced to protest on
police violence that's
disproportionately killing black people
in the midst of a pandemic that's also
disproportionately killing black people
[Music]
we realize that the only way to you know
combat these two pandemics is not by
staying inside our homes
by actually coming outside our homes and
helping one another
we cannot fight these pandemics by being
quiet or
being silent about the issues and how
disproportionately affected black people
in america
that we have to be loud that we have to
be bold and that we're going to have to
be courageous
that going outside may kill us you know
because of the pandemic
but going outside as a black person in
america has been killing us for over 400
years
no justice
[Music]
in memphis when dr martin luther king
was murdered 52 years ago
the police locked down the streets
action is necessary change is necessary
i couldn't just stand by and not allow
myself to speak up
black lives matter all of our black
lives matter
[Applause]
in phoenix arizona the streets echo with
the sound of people demanding justice
[Music]
[Applause]
and in ohio the state where 13 unarmed
anti-war protesters were shot by the
national guard in 1970
[Applause]
police used pepper spray to try to
disperse the crowd
in minneapolis the violence intensifies
with arson and lutein breaking out
across the city
but many at the heart of the protest
insist the criminality has to be seen in
a wider context
sometimes i give a chuckle and some
americans say
that you know we need to stop looting
when america was based off the looting
of land
the looting of black bodies the looting
of on wages and eluding of labor
america was built off of theft
while others insist that it should not
be allowed to overshadow more serious
crimes
i can't focus on that part there's so
many reasons
whoever the looters are i focused on the
part of
getting justice not being distracted my
father said something like
it's important as you grow and you learn
that you
learn how to think for yourself see for
yourself and hear for yourself
so that you don't so that you can better
judge for yourself and not allow
yourself to be
caught up in distractions or caught up
in things that are divisive
that the goal is to make sure that these
unlawful killings end
late in the evening the demonstrators
seized control of the police precinct
near to where george floyd was killed
it is burnt to the ground
the police have now lost control of
large areas of the city
[Applause]
and the president of the united states
addresses the nation
via twitter these thugs
are dishonoring the memory of george
floyd and i won't let that happen
he assures the state governor the
military are with him all the way
he concludes when the luton starts the
shooting starts
in a humiliating repost the moderators
of twitter
informed donald trump that his message
has violated their rules on glorifying
violence
[Music]
in scenes that echoed the civil unrest
of the 1960s
the governor of minnesota calls in the
national guard
my first and foremost responsibility to
the state of minnesota
is the safety and security of all
citizens
we cannot have the looting and the
recklessness that went on
we cannot have it because we can't
function as a society
and i refuse to have it take away the
attention
of the stain that we need to be working
on
after three days of rioting the eyes of
the world are now on minneapolis
and the events that unfold are
unparalleled in american history yep
we've got one person uh being arrested
here
[Music]
we've got we're meeting up yep we're
good
put us put us back where you want us we
are getting out of your way so
just let us know wherever you'd want us
we will we will go we are just getting
out of your way when you're advancing
through the intersection
this is among the state patrol unit that
was advancing
up the street saying and scattering the
protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away
i'm sorry okay do you mind telling me
why i'm under arrest sir
why why am i under arrest
an afro-latina reporter doing his job is
detained live in front of an
international audience
that is an american television reporter
omar jimenez being led away
by police officers for a country that
enshrines freedom of speech in its own
constitution
it's a sign that america has now plunged
into unchartered waters
uh i believe they're about to um we're
all about to be arrested that's not
our producer i think it's horrible and
disgusting
that we're living in a country who
prides itself on free speech
prides itself on freedom of the press
that's arresting
um mainstream journalists and also
citizen journalists that are documenting
it
on their live streams and what we're
trying to do is show the world
what's really going on we're just
passing along the message
your message just by arresting us you
are literally proving our point
that the uh officers in the law are
taking a heavy-handed approach
towards protests
i'm being arrested now
i gotta put the camera down
[Applause]
later that day derek chauvin is charged
with third-degree murder
and the manslaughter of george floyd
crazy bro you can at least lifted him up
off the ground
according to the minnesota statute third
degree murder does not require an intent
to kill
you the combined charges
carry a maximum sentence of 35 years
i don't think you can really settle with
just the arrest of
just one of the officers i feel like it
needs to be every officer involved even
the officer that was witnessing it
happened in front of his face
if you have a cell phone and you take
the cell phone and you set
the stop watch for nine minutes
and you just sit there and let the time
pass
and think about somebody with their knee
on your
neck and you're struggling to breathe
and they won't
remove it until you suffocate
well that is the last minutes of brew
of george floyd's life and it's just
in a word murder there's no way you can
justify this protests
are continuing to spread across america
[Applause]
in new york where eric garner died after
being choked by the police
confrontations are growing more
now comparisons are being made with the
civil rights clashes of 1968
[Music]
one of the most divisive years in
america's history
others who lived through those times
start to recognize there is a difference
at first i was like oh no no no you know
because
it was 68 all over again and we lost
to an extent
and then the looters came in and the
people were riding
something flipped
it might have been uh because of social
media because people could talk to one
another and get to one another faster
because my generation we couldn't talk
to one another so
it might be that that happened and
people could sort of mesh
things together people of asian descent
who were being berated
by this president because the
coronavirus people who had grown up were
americans
they just had chinese ancestry we were
getting like harangued in the streets
they suddenly saw something in black
lives matter for them
indigenous people suddenly saw something
and black lives matter for them
[Music]
white kids who were anti-racist or for
the environment
or wanted change they saw something in
black lives matter for them
people in my generations particularly
old stages who've been out there always
marching marching for this
they saw something in black lives matter
for them
the difference was black lives matter
has not said
stay out of our fight that's the
difference we
said to white people stay out of it
isn't anything to do with you and it
didn't
then but for this generation black lives
matter blm is saying yeah there's a
pocket of this that you you can pick up
the diversity of the protesters may have
changed but the violence on the streets
is all too familiar
[Music]
in atlanta cnn a network watched in over
200 countries
is now a target for the crowd's fury
one of the city's most influential
figures insists the lawlessness
is counterproductive in this city
you can find over 50 restaurants owned
by black women
i didn't say minority and i didn't say
women of color
so after you burn down your own home
what do you have left
for char and ash
what i can tell you is that if you sit
in your homes tonight
instead of burning your home to the
ground you will have time to properly
plot
plan strategize and organize and
mobilize an
effective way
as the protest spreads more and more
incidents of the police response
are relayed around the world
in buffalo new york a 75 year old
attempts a one-man protest
[Applause]
in new york city the police strike back
against demonstrators
and in minneapolis rubber bullets and
pepper spray are fired at the crowds
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump in the middle of the
civil unrest
donald trump addresses the nation thank
you very much
with the u.s election less than five
months away donald trump is quick to
position himself as the candidate of
zero tolerance
my fellow americans my first and highest
duty
as president is to defend our great
country
and the american people i swore an oath
to uphold the
laws of our nation and that is exactly
what i will do
all americans were rightly sickened
and revolted by the brutal death
of george floyd my administration is
fully committed
that for george and his family justice
will be served
he will not have died in vain
but we cannot allow the righteous cries
and peaceful protesters
to be drowned out by an angry mob
we are ending the riots and lawlessness
that has spread throughout our country
we will end it now
today i have strongly recommended to
every governor
to deploy the national guard
in sufficient numbers that we dominate
the streets
mayors and governors must establish an
overwhelming law enforcement presence
until the violence has been quelled
if a city or state refuses to take the
actions that are necessary to defend the
life and property
of their residents then i will deploy
the united states military
and quickly solve the problem for them
the speech comes from a president who a
year ago described himself as the least
racist person in the world
it's not a portrait that many of his
fellow americans recognize
but now this is interesting because he's
in a mess
he's getting everything wrong every
possible thing you could do
he's doing it wrong because
americans what americans want and expect
even the most cynical
even the most non-voting think that the
president of the united states job
is to unify us at a moment like this
the president nixon did it
johnson did it kennedy did it
bush did it both bushes did it reagan
did it
uh bill clinton did it barack obama did
it
you stand up you broadcast from the oval
office behind the resolute desk
and you say my fellow americans
why because it wouldn't be real
because he's a racist he really really
is and this is the tell
this murder he can't bring himself
to be even a modicum of sincerity
a short distance from the white house a
crowd has gathered in response to the
president's speech
[Music]
the police move in with what the new
york times describes
as a burst of violence unlike any scene
in the shadow
of the white house in generations
the unprovoked action clears the way for
a five-minute presidential photo
opportunity
in which he poses with a bible carried
in his daughter's handbag
the protests have now inevitably become
a battleground between the main
political parties
with peaceful protesters dispersed an
order for a president
a president from the doorstep of the
people's house the white house
using tear gas and flash grenades in
order to stage a photo
op a photo op i'm one of the most
historic churches in
the country or at least in washington dc
we can be forgiven for believing the
president is more interested in
in power than in principle
but for many of this new generation of
protesters
traditional politics is part of the
problem and not the solution
what's going on is above republican and
democrats
in 2013 when we talked about george
zimmerman and trayvon martin
that all occurred um with a democratic
president a black
democratic president president obama
and we didn't see the changes that we
needed to see in order to
evade this moment that we're in right
now so i'm not convinced
that just having a democratic president
or black elected officials is going to
change anything
what's going to change anything is us
not trying to diversify
or change who is in these positions of
power but really trying to dismantle
these positions of power so that they
don't have control
or power over other people's lives and
these
are the things that the black lives
matter movement is talking about and
having these conversations about
to get people to understand that we
don't want people
to climb up this ladder we want this
ladder to be knocked down
by the beginning of june 5 000 members
of the national guard have been deployed
across 15 states
and washington dc and nearly half the
country's 50 states
are on the curfew
[Music]
the family has called for peace
the family has called for peace
the family has called for peace
[Music]
hundreds of mourners gather at the spot
where george floyd was
[Music]
but killed because we're doing it
peacefully
that doesn't mean we don't want
all four of the officers locked up
[Applause]
it has become a monument not just to one
black life
but to centuries of racial injustice
once again there are pleas for the
violence to stop
i understand y'all upset
[Music]
blowing up stuff if i'm not over here
messing up my community
what are y'all doing
[Music]
what are y'all doing y'all doing nothing
because that's not gonna bring my
brother back at all
[Music]
my family is a peaceful family my family
is god
fearing
yeah we upset but we're not gonna take
it we're not gonna be
repetitious let's do this another way
let's stop thinking that our voice don't
matter
and vote not just vote for the president
but for the preliminaries
vote for everybody
[Applause]
now one man's death in minneapolis
picked up and amplified by social media
sparks the first
truly global protest movement for racial
justice
i see george ford on tv it made me feel
angry
no human being should have to suffer
that he died
no better than an animal in the street
[Applause]
no it's just not acceptable one death
being bad
is not good enough every death is bad
and we need to make sure that that
stops here and now social media
has completely changed the landscape of
fighting for
injustice it's given us the power to
tell our stories where we didn't
necessarily have it before
so often before we had to rely on
mainstream media
to to show our stories it's not enough
to be
neutral there is no such thing as being
neutral
in a fight for injustice you are either
on the side of the oppressed
or on the side of the oppressor in order
to be
on the side of the press you have to
stand with us and be loud
and bold and courageous otherwise you
are on the side of
the oppressor you're silencing us you're
not helping us
you're not advocating for us britain is
slowly coming out of the coronavirus
lockdown
people ignore the advice of the
government and the streets are filled
with protesters showing their solidarity
[Music]
more education black awareness
i want to be able to have that in this
country my first staff of us being
unified
look at us we're in 2020 and this is
what we're doing we're having to walk
and to mark
black lives matter
well racism kills lives every day every
day before the pandemic black people
were still dying
so i was down here to fight for the
people that were dying today that were
dying yesterday
400 years ago
in parliament the prime minister's
response is a recognition that
more needs to be done for racial
equality in britain
i understand the very strong and
legitimate feelings of people in this
country at the death of
of george floyd and of course i agree
that
black lives matter but i must stress
that on the lamy report
and on all these matters it is
absolutely vital
at the same time that we keep our
streets
safe and that we back our police
but like america a new generation of
black people refuse to accept the
assurances of politicians
racism is so deeply embedded in the
social structure it's like a disease and
it's a genetic illness
it can't be reformed out there's no way
to get rid of racism without getting rid
of what we understand to be the
political
economy
like america the british supporters of
black lives matter
point to slavery as the original sin
that has yet to be cleansed
in bristol a crowd descends on the
statue of the 18th century slaver
edward colston
[Applause]
and vent their outrage against the
monument of a man whose fortune was
founded on racist exploitation
[Music]
in the united states record numbers have
taken to the streets
[Music]
but now there is an historic change in
the response from law enforcement
we implore you please taken me in
solidarity with
us
[Applause]
if i could take a knee with the
community to garner and broke a piece
that i'll get on my knee every day
baton charges and tear gas are put to
one side
as police and protesters share their
common humanity
the case against those present at george
floyd's killing changes once more
derek shoving is now formally accused of
second-degree murder
and faces a possible 40-year prison
sentence
[Music]
thomas lane is charged with aiding and
abetting degree murder
and aiding and abetting manslaughter
tu tau also faces the same charges
as does j alexander king
i strongly believe that these
developments are in the interest of
justice
for mr floyd his family our community
and our state
but for black people white dominated law
enforcement has consistently
failed to deliver justice
and the death of george floyd underlines
a problem that has remained
unresolved for generations
at the end of the day you knew
that you weren't safe in the country you
were born in
you knew even as a woman that you didn't
want to call the police
because a they may not show up in your
domain
and b if they do something might happen
to you
and certainly if you're a man and even
to this day
uh little black boys are given what's
called the talk
where you're told and your little guy
seven eight years old
the police pull you over you don't say
i'm gonna give him my new you don't go
and get your id
you put your hands on the wheel and you
look straight ahead
you don't look anybody in the eye and
you don't speak
for black lives matter this state of
affairs can no longer stand
[Music]
and they now call for a revolution in
the policing of their neighborhoods
i'm completely for defunding the police
i believe and i know from history that
the police
are a racist institution and emerged
from slave patrols
and that they existed to repress and
support on white nationalist groups like
the kkk
throughout history and that it was never
here necessarily to support
or protect black people but it is here
to protect
property private property and white
supremacy gonna be all right
so in order to protect our communities
we know that the safest and strongest
communities
don't have more police officers the
safest and strongest communities have
better access to resources
they have better jobs they have better
health care they have better homes
access to better foods so when we look
at more police officers
don't say in order for our communities
to be more safe we need more cops
in order for our communities be more
safe we need access to better resources
but this demand for fundamental change
is one that even the most progressive
members of the political establishment
find hard to accept
i am entirely committed
to seeing through massive
transformational
and structural reform to how the
minneapolis police department operates
if the question is
you know if we're reimagining entirely
what the minneapolis police department
looks like i am entirely in favor of it
um however as i've mentioned previously
i'm not for abolition of the police
department
and for a president forced to fill the
streets of the nation's capital with
heavily armed officers
the proposition is simply non-negotiable
they won't be defunding there won't be
dismantling of our police
and they're not going to be any
disbanding of our police our police have
been
letting us live in peace and we want to
make sure we don't have any
bad actors in there
now that the worst of the violence
across the country has subsided
it is time for america to take stock
[Music]
the images of burnt out communities and
destroyed livelihoods
will be used by many to say the country
has been here before
and nothing will change
[Music]
but there is now a growing certainty
that the death of george floyd marks a
turning point in history
[Music]
and this time the truth about racial
injustice in america can no longer be
buried
[Music]
you saw what you saw everything happened
in real time
here's how it happened the act happened
we caught them we released the footage
they tried to deny it
me and my friends from dragon walk
looked at the footage gave it to the
washington post
what you see now is no escape
from this everyone saw what they saw in
real time
there was not a six to 12 month gap
of a case litigation evidence
what happened before right that's always
been the question
what happened before that did he deserve
it did he resist
once that second video came immediately
is when everything happened that's when
it happened
and now that we saw it in real time with
no filters
no slicing the dyson of the footage
everybody saw the truth
does it not speak for itself do you guys
have riots where you're from
this is no different but the difference
with this
and why it's a tipping point is simply
because
we saw it in real time
the road to justice and equality in the
usa has been long
and hard and the journey is by no means
over
my father said that it would be this
generation
that would get sick and tired that they
would recognize
the people in power have misused it
and that they will no longer sit by idly
and allow these injustices
to continue i saw many people's
protesting signs and it said we are not
our ancestors
you know and then it followed up with
what we will do
if you continue to do these kinds of
horrible acts
those who have trod the path over
generations have witnessed
great triumphs and unimaginable tragedy
when the conversation he shot
he died instantly we were
refusing that one for the killer
movement
he was killed when he watched the
purpose campaign he died we
we had a big commission gary we began to
come out way wake up and fight back
politically
so the progress we made since he's been
there's been enormous progress
and now is a time for a new generation
to follow in their footsteps
i'm not quite sure if i believe that the
black lives matter protests are
different from the the protests in the
past i think that the black lives matter
movement is just a reiteration of the
black lives of the black
power movement in the past that we are
still fighting for our rights
things may have changed we have may
learn different things and
um but the the goal is still the same
that
we want freedom for black people and
liberation for black people
we've seen that we've been fighting for
this thing for over 50 years or
60 or 70 years and we still haven't
gotten the things that we deserve
and the things that we've been asking
for so things have to change now and we
have to wrap it up
and have a stronger demands to ensure we
get the things that we need
[Music]
when you leave
[Music]
there was a time when the killing of a
46 year old black man in police custody
would have passed almost unnoticed
[Music]
but today the whole world knows how
george floyd's life was taken
as his family gathered to mourn his
death there were demands for america
to look into its soul
[Music]
no more hate crimes please someone said
make america great again
but when has america ever been great
[Applause]
and the promise that his passing will
never be forgotten
[Music]
[Applause]
as we lay you to rest today
the movement won't rest until we get
justice
until we have one standard of justice
your family is going to miss you george
but your nation is going to always
remember your name
because your neck was one that
represented all of us
and how you suffered represented our
suffering
you fought a good fight you kept the
faith
you finished your course go on and get
your rest now
go on and see mama now we gonna fight
off
we gonna fight off we gonna fight on
we gonna fight off
[Music]
seventy years ago the great american
novelist ralph ellison
wrote of his plight as a black man in
his own country
i am invisible understand
simply because people refuse to see me
[Music]
george floyd is no longer invisible
he is now a symbol of a past and a
present
people refuse to accept any longer
and above all he is a symbol of hope
for a better future
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you